[Aplausos]
quando era menina lá em salvador
eu não vi a diversidade
pelo contrário da mídia as referências
que tinham era próximo de mim todos os
dias mulheres sobretudo loiras
apresentava os programas infantis era um
protagonista das novelas estavam por
toda parte
mais tarde quando vim morar em são paulo
eu trabalhei nas principais agências do
brasil e com um conteúdo de marca
constantemente havia uma resistência
muito grande na inclusão de negros em
peças publicitárias
era comum esse tipo de peça sempre
voltava o cliente falava
esse não é o target que a gente quer
atingir
falando de forma clara era racismo
aquilo sempre me incomodou e no ano
passado esse incômodo virou pesquisa eu
trabalhava como curadora de conteúdo de
um aplicativo de beleza e além de fazer
os textos eu também escolhas que quais
são quais eram as blogueiras que iam pro
a nossa conversa com a minha equipe
o termo beleza negra tinha sido o mais
buscado pelos assinantes do epp
aquilo ficou na minha mente de uma forma
tão grande que resolvi relacioná o termo
beleza negra e o quanto as marcas de
beleza com risco as correspondiam no
youtube
fiz o recorde dos vídeos assistir
centenas de vídeos de marcas das sete
marcas mais buscadas pelos brasileiros
no google e e constatei vários problemas
o primeiro deles é que a primeira é a
segunda marca elas têm 30 e 29 por cento
de representatividade
eu contei na unha quando os negros avião
em suas produções é pouco é muito pouco
muita gente acha a 30% é muito mas é
pouco 54% da população brasileira é
negra e esse número tende a aumentar a
nossa autoestima está crescendo e além
disso os vídeos publicitários que eu fiz
o recorte ela somente aqueles que irão
para o ar ou seja dentro do recorte que
eu fiz
encontrei 30 e 29% se sente representado
é muito importante quando a gente fala
de representatividade
parece que a gente está pedindo caridade
das marcas não é caridade nunca vai ser
realidade
isso me lembra que no final da pesquisa
eu pedi mais diversidade por favor e com
valor
muitos acham que a inclusão já é
suficiente mas vai ficar acontece você
somente inclui o negro não é o ideal
a gente que está presente dentro da
narrativa de forma importante e sabe que
isso me lembra isso me lembra a história
de um game
eu sempre adorei os jogos eletrônicos e
desde a minha adolescência que eu jogava
onde está e 3d
eu adquiri uma preferência por jogos de
tiro de guerra
pode parecer estranho pra mim na globo
eu em quando eu comprei meu primeiro
videogame já tinha passado dos 30 sim eu
já tenho mais de 30
eu comprei um jogo chamado by o choque
em finish
e foi jogando e jogando e o jogo é
extremamente violento mas sobre isso eu
quero falar
existe um era ainda o melhor o anti era
ainda negra dentro da narrativa
essa é a base desde fitz roy a daisy é
anti herói na negra dentro do jogo
ela lidera um armada de excluídos que
tenta tomar colômbia colômbia é uma
cidade racista em tolerante e se e com
pessoas cercadas de privilégios
durante o jogo eu comecei eu comecei a
jogar e quando eu me deparei com a day
eu confesso que eu não sabia o que fazer
sua cena sua grande primeira cena dura
quase cinco minutos ela explica por que
ela lidera a revolução porque ela quer
tomado colômbia a daisy é um é um
exemplo muito simbólico que diz
a gente que está presente na narrativa
de forma importante ela tem ela faz
ações que muda completamente o estilo do
jogador
essa sua cena que eu sinto agora é um
off é uma forma de te dar uma missão
você como jogador
ela te dá uma missão e você vai pra
favela adquire armas para se juntar à
revolução nossa todo no spoiler do jogo
terrível porque é importante a presença
da deise porque pra mim foi tão
impactante provavelmente se você é um
cara branco você não jogou mesmo jogo
que eu joguei o impacto não foi o mesmo
não foi e é por isso que a
representatividade é importante porque a
daisy ela é extremamente importante
dentro da narrativa e é isso que a gente
quer a gente não quer a presença pela
presença a gente quer a presença que
seja importante diversidade não é
caridade diversidade não é otimismo
diversidade é normalidade
isso não foi visto assim todos nós
perdemos todos nós
obrigado
[Aplausos]